we got Bob Saget on zoom' you can watch
on youtube.com / the Dan Patrick show
what kind of what kind of stuff do you
have in your man cave there Bob my wife
a couple of jewels
nice TVs I got some cool memorabilia
like important stuff from you know
Richard Pryor and Rodney some Chapel and
stuff I collect some things but pretty
much just in human life pretty much is
it in your room right now like behind
you do you have this behind me I've got
like Dodger baseball bobbleheads it's
pathetic what do you have for Richard
Pryor I've got a bunch of stuff a
picture of a Richards sign for me and I
was in a movie with him called critical
condition so Richard and I have a had a
closeness it was I loved them a lot how
intimidating was Pryor back then well I
was at the Comedy Store for like eight
years
so I was just the bear as an emcee
trying to get a job I would do little
gigs here and there and so I would be on
stage and I'd bring Robin Williams up
and then you know rest his soul whatever
the hell you say
because he shouldn't be dead and then
I'd bring Richard up and then Sam
Kennison would go on it wasn't saying it
was its popular again well it's not
bother them now you can't go anywhere
but but Richard was was pretty
astonishing it was but who got up there
and killed where you go I I can't I
can't do this this is this is out of my
league well as far as I'm concerned no
one yeah well we all know how to kill at
a certain point we can all set it on
stun if you've been doing I've been
doing it 43 years so during that time I
bombed do you know off and on for a
decade and you have to do that to get
good pretty much but the person that was
most impressed with was Eddie Murphy he
was working out raw and I brought him
onstage one week and he you know
unbelievable standing ovations at the
top the walls are shaking and then it he
did great and then at the end I hate all
their euphemisms if they give you you
know
killed he crushed he smashed he wrecked
it I crushed that you don't want to hear
that when it comes to another person of
the opposite sex or the same sex or just
some unsuspecting you know traffic
officer back to Eddie Murphy you thank
you god bless you
so he came in one week did the set he
was in a blue leather suit it was on a
Friday night did about 50 minutes and
then one Friday later this is right
before he was shooting raw like two
weeks before he shot raw he was wearing
an all red leather suit came in the room
rumbled walls are shaking and then at
the the set just built he literally was
so good that and I understood what he
was doing he fixed everything that he
was doing he fixed it he understood it
more he told it he elongated it because
he told it more as a person would tell
it like Richard that's kind of the role
model for how you tell the story you
embellish it and he wasn't working on at
that point he was refining it and
literally it was the biggest reaction
I'd ever seen to anyone except for one
set I had in central but but it was
amazed I'm literally the walls shook and
it was the main room which is like a
400-seat room which used to be C rows so
yeah yeah it was it was astonishing I
mean and I and Robin always would kill
you know but sometimes the best people
like Richard we just take chances which
and Chapelle does that bill burr they go
on stage and you don't know where the
valleys are they're not going up once in
a while it feels good to go up and go
I'm gonna I feel like killing tonight
I'm gonna I'm gonna just not try
anything that new or if I try something
new it's gonna be in the middle and I'm
gonna be all amped up kind of like an
athlete that goes okay I'm so you don't
know when you're in the zone but if you
feel that you're in the zone then you
can do no wrong what would Kinnison be
like nowadays hey I think he'd be where
he is right now
not alive he was actually clean and
sober when he was hit by that car
I loved him I got him his first I'm a
hundred years old I got him his first
spot at The Comedy Store I also
introduced from the Rodney Dangerfield
never odd you put it on back to school
and then I was in the young comedians
special with Sam that kind of discovered
him and then all Rodney did all the time
he was a friend of mine Rodney and and
he would go man that's Sam he's
unbelievable man
Sam Sam Sam Sam and then Ron Jeremy
would come over and I'm like Sam ron
jeremy you guys have fun have a good
night you know I'm gonna I'm gonna go
home and be so you know you were married
at the time yeah yeah when I got
divorced I would then I would take
Rodney out to dinner and at one time I
didn't call to confirm and Ron Jeremy
was coming up with two hookers to sign a
release that Rodney wanted to sign so he
could put in his book and they were
gonna get stoned and just hang out and
then Rodney I said Rodney haven't we had
dinner at 7:00 he said you didn't call
to confirm you didn't call and he's
wearing a robe he's got no underwear on
and it's like he's got a janitor to set
of keys hanging out of it basically
naked I don't think you need to say
hanging out with Jeremy in the same
sentence I didn't I wasn't there and Ron
Jeremy's a big fan of comedy so I was
doing a benefit for my scleroderma
Research Foundation it's not mine it's
everybody's and that's a disease my
sister died from and so ron jeremy he
was at the Vegas event and really wanted
me to sign my book to him and he wanted
to get in the backstage and I didn't
know that and he blocked the door with
his unit was incredibly no we got it we
got it we got it
Yeah right no I got uh so I signed it
and then I shook his hand that ain't
happening you sunzha you signed the book
no I signed it
okay I had four sharp I did he's Bob
Saget he's got a podcast it's called Bob
Saget's here for you yeah who do you
want
interview if I said pick anybody and you
got him for an hour well I'm doing it
besides you yeah I'm doing it
i-i've been talking to I've been doing
some monologues by myself where I'm just
trying to figure out what the hell's
going on and trying to give people a
little bit of comfort and I plan to do
this thing before all of this happen so
I went did two episodes where we were
able to put it on tape but it's on the
YouTube site that bears my name but
basically my first guest was John Stamos
because that's a prerequisite and coming
up now in the I've got three shows that
came out this week first two weeks I did
three episodes then I go to Monday
Thursday and I'm John Stamos Tiffany
Haddish bill burr Howie Mandel Macaulay
Culkin John Mayer got Seth Green coming
up Jim Gaffigan so it's people that I
love that I've known a long time because
we all came up together so I'll pretty
much try to get all my friends but then
you Lee can you just Bullock Macaulay to
tap into home like his I can't imagine
he wants to revisit home alone we did it
we did it I recorded it last week and I
think it's on it's on Friday
I think it's on this week I'm not sure
about the scheduling all the time
because it's done you know very high-end
at a secret lab by like horse for genius
twenty-five-year-old it's like I didn't
even realize it it's like who runs a
puppy or an apple podcast okay who runs
that and it's like five genius twenty
five year old so I'm like okay cool they
know what they're doing dammit and could
be your next wife no no no it's mostly
dudes it's a couple of ladies Oh
actually no I'm sorry my engineer is
this brilliant lady named Anneliese and
she I can't believe what she does
because I'm uploading her it sounds
wrong my wife's in the house I'm not
uploading her honey she's not
downloading downloading either no no
downloading no uploading did you get her
I got a good pin though my pins fast
when you were
when you did full house were you a
sports anchor love at first yes and they
found that I didn't know a lot so they
decided the search we order a morning
talk show host which I ended up doing oh
yeah I did that before I did full house
but yeah I was a big you know Golden
State Warriors and but do you know
anything about sports a little bit I
mean you run your you score I mean I can
make I did a movie I did TV movie once
where I had to I was playing basketball
with my son and I can shoot you know
sometimes you're a total guy your that's
the best thing their main job every time
I would jump to make a layup I would my
feet would come up in the back and kick
myself in the ass so there was a Russian
basketball player was a pop off or
something error what was his name Navis
I don't know Alexander Beloff was that
the guy that would kick himself in the
boat with his feet when he made a layup
I'm you to just say yes all right so you
won yeah I've got I've got this for you
this is from Don Rickles 80th birthday
all right all right I mean the the prior
think it would have been better let me
give you something more valuable there
you go
I like Purell very doesn't yeah so so
yeah I'll be able to I'm able to fake it
I didn't have a double but I'm not I'm
not I wasn't there I chosen on the teams
did you talk women with John Mayer or
watches because he's a big watch guy I
don't know I see a bigger watch guy or
women guy the same thing because you
want to get your hand on the face okay
well I got you your little hands on your
[Laughter]
butt what happened was no we've been
friends a long time and and it was it
was about 90 minutes my good interviews
have been like 90 minutes long stainless
was 90 minutes ironically it was exactly
the same as the mayor interview um not
was mayor's interview we didn't really
talk women because we know each other so
we're friends so we didn't need to do
that
cuz it wasn't it was like when your
friend you know when you have a friend
on not the I mean if we were buddies all
the time you wouldn't go you wouldn't
ask me the same questions you know yeah
but nobody's the questions though Bob
for your audience not for you well it's
weird because a lot of people like Bill
burr just tie cheating me he's like
don't ask questions this is a
conversation this is a podcast and then
he told me what my stand-up is he said
you know your stand-up his Bob it's who
he grills me for like 25 minutes he
beats the living hell out of me he says
your stand-up is nothing more than the
lines they couldn't use on a house and
then you just drop f-bombs around it he
said that's all your stand-up is and so
after about half an hour of getting
pummeled by Bill burr who is one of the
funniest people news he's Bob Saget he's
here for you in more ways than one Bob
it's always great to talk to you and I
always enjoy talking to you I just wish
you a lot of health you got a nice place
you got nice digs there the show's done
you well all the other guys are living
in poverty I can see it right now thank
you Bob
you're a good man thank you so much be
well that's a Bob Saget Bob Saget's here
for you podcast it's available on iTunes
and Amazon and always good to catch up
with him